hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play that's face - ah ah ah what
the hell
kidding I'm in space now what my she
woke up but you know oh yeah he's run
off people and gone yawns I've got
problems on this into what is it
somewhere safe
I'll try how can you just be okay Ruby
yeah that Ruby looked like bronze I
swear what am i doing I'm going in there
what why what's in here I swear you just
got pulled by an arm by a giant tentacle
through a few rock walls how can you be
okay i doing give their laser beams
oh I need to move them Oh because
they're appointed at that door oh well
that's obviously unnatural that they're
all pointed at the door like that just
got to say that right now okay maybe I
can tap it with a fire there we go at
work Adil - okay I need to get another
one there must be some goodies around
here
there must be right because it seems
like goodie heaven all my things
oriented ground ooh pretty view oh it's
exploding why why is it exploding
seriously why is it exploding anyway I
need air holy crap where's the air
oh right here okay we're good man to
ground or en tuck around stay orient
okay ah there it is goodie goodie goodie
goodie goodie
peridot yeah yeah oh this one's already
got one
pshh that was that one yeah okay we're
all clear right are we I don't know
nicely since whatever I'm going in
maybe these would be good for those
did that die I didn't hear its death
well but I guess in space you can't hear
weird exploding tumors die got him
I think get down to the ground burn it
down
burn it down to the ground burn it down
what this oh they won't fall back down
in zero-g so they'll have to burn all of
them with afterburner Oh chain reaction
look up okay that's all of them
we're good Pompey form the silly Isaac
Clark walk but what one had to do okay
ah right well that was a detour I
suppose Ellie I'm back inside where are
you
we're Stross safe for now but he's lost
it I think he's coming for you uh-huh
I found something you're gonna want to
see here's my location
hurry and get here and learn any shape
to be fighting Oh got it baby stay safe
I'll be protect you like a particular
way what save flamethrower is actually
very useful in certain situations I
didn't like it before but like it's like
my rapid fire thing it's great for those
little packs I know that already
yeah my line racks see I got plenty of
debt hello
goodies give me juice what that ah my
goodies what you owe
how about summer death oh look someone
gift ha ha
Oh what the hell you BAM suck on that
you made me lose my box where's the body
of the big one
ah come on box go it's gone
whoa hello
whoops whoops oh hello
bring it alive not for long oh good
it's gonna pop out at me functions in
close range
detonator but when have I ever done
anything smart or this this is probably
not oh there we go
what ah hey head it can't that [ __ ] yeah
oh my goodness
I mean holy ah-ah-ah I thought it died
when I hit the dead nah okay that was
Scala's my bad that was all my bed okay
but I know where to set up traps now
that's some
flipping put it up damn it
knocking his butt baby come on bro
what's up cam okay now another one
their food you're not gonna die
doesn't always one-shot sometime Noah
Bobby give me that
Oh yep expert bro oh darn oh yeah so
great okay I'm gonna need a couple traps
over here now one shot that one why
didn't one shot any others I'll put two
bucks oh those are just gonna go ah I
knew it I knew it I knew it
oh god bro come at me another what
kidding me there we go
apparently it doesn't hurt them all that
much if you just fire it at their face
you really need to give this step on it
ah DP ah
what what that didn't kill you sometimes
I've shot those things three times I'm a
guy and other times I can shoot him
haha nope shoot him and impale them and
there you see just like that he just
falls over dead
oh hello Arthur
we're good did I get them partner the
first time or the second time I'm losing
track so whenever I die okay
good pro I don't look mine was an
attention shoot worker
your creepy power node room yeah Judith
who would pass suit
Ruby is that Ruby I was just a bronze
freaking bronze giant pile oh crap
biggest rap now [ __ ] hello not really
doing me any harmful their best mate
time to burn youtuber DDOT where's
another one
ah there you are
it does do considerable damage over I
think I know crow come on ha ha ha no II
gotta help what why would you take the
helmet off tell her one yeah oh oh wow
did you do it wrong
why did you take off your helmet it's
not like his screwdriver mashing get
anything to you ah poor Stross
I still don't trust you oh oh hello how
do you lock that was for Ellie yeah you
killed her
I'm serious I want you to stop
you're going crazy but what wait a
minute I'm right back where I was what
the hell
seriously why am i why am i back here
why did I go in one big circle for point
of all that in there whatever why didn't
I just go there first another to think
your rig I'll need to sink my rig hell I
mean seriously why going that mixer well
it's gonna come out of it whoa Donna
chilly Danielle he's going crazy
okay be ready for what pigma to my
imagination
matter oh where did you come from oh my
goodness my heart oh goody sauce
hauling this felt like elevators haha
I'm ill-equipped for an elevator at the
moment all right guess I'll use the line
Rex hopefully they'll give me big clumps
I say fall from the ceiling which I know
they're gonna
being on this year
get some
ah ah where'd you come from how can it
not be dad
Wow trying to grab as many spikes as I
can save ammo
not good
how do they sneak up on me when I'm in a
corner
haha you you're not dead
just Peggy Peggy pretending ah ah what
what Oh honky I was at full health Oh
see the crap I have to put up with
Oh baloney
Oh whew Wow Wow
have you laughs you in your face
I like those guys I'm ill-equipped yo
ever
make on this year
okay bring it on
so ready
no not today go on
good aim for the arms
come on I'm ready for you
here ya know
what how could you hit me
[ __ ]
not today
come on head him the little one should
not take that much
kidding me
morning
fricken hitting a bride in the gullet I
did not need to throw my detonator mines
sorry about that
Jamie things cannot be this stuff one
shot him sometimes but I mean there's
ice which is bad I wonder which what I
am anyway that's all the time I got for
this part thank you guys again for
watching I hope you enjoying it and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye